in this video we are going to continue
the cat model we were talking from
last video and specifically talk about
the production process
and how to make this ring into this one
are you ready let's get started
if you haven't watched this video how to
make this model
don't forget to watch it first this
video is about the production process
that's starting with 3d printing there
are different kind of 3d printer there
i use b9 creation and this is
the result image that i would like to
show you
after that i cast them and get rid of
the spool and this is the
starting for finish at the very
beginning you're going to find out
on the casting you have some line
created by the printing layer
depends on the resolution that you have
you always will
end up with some small line and those
lines are easy to
remove by sandpaper here is my
homemade sandpaper by wrapping a stick
with 280 grit sandpaper
make sure they are flat and tight and
i'm just going to
some larger area you don't have to worry
too much inside because my stone
is not transparent so
i just need to make sure outside is nice
and polished
before i actually get into the stone
setting
you can see i try to smooth out as much
as
possible and then you can go a little
bit finer
after this one you can go up to 400 grit
anything after that i think it's just
personal preference i would like to use
polish machine to do the rest of the job
after that i will use the brown polish
wheel
i bought this from the rio grande and
here's
i will put the link below for you to
check out them everybody have a
different preference
i've been using this for a while this is
a little bit
abrasive so if you have minor scratch
it will be easy to remove
be really careful on one thing is
anything is
abrasive that create heat so if your
stone
is um heat sensitive
like opal then you will be really
careful
once you have a stone in there using
this wheel and i will show you
just in a few minutes now we finish the
outside that's
cleaning the inside a little bit you may
have some rough surface
left from the casting so we don't have
to polish inside
because it's opaque stone however i
would like to remove
any of the bumpy surface
inside if possible so here i'm trying to
use the
bulbar to clean up inside and try to
rough the surface a little bit
my stone is very soft so if inside is
not completely flat or you have any of
the
imperfection close to the h when you try
to push the metal against it then you
will crack the stone
and double make sure the size is correct
using the plastic hammer
on the ring mandrel to shape the ring
if your ring is not smooth
you can use the file and i usually use
half round file to smooth out the button
especially where you had the screw in
there and sometimes when you just cut
off the sprue
it is not smooth so i want to make sure
the
ring chain is tapered down smoothly so i
just
wanted to work on it a little bit the
same rubber wheel
you can shape it into the smaller size
or use the old one
and you can shape the rubber wheel with
the
a piece of the old file and use that for
shaping it
and here i want to make sure all the
corners nice and round
so it's not going to cut into the finger
or scratch the finger
when the customer wear it and once again
it's a lot of back and forth filing
smoothing
and make sure everything's nice and
perfect before we get into the polished
machine
and i just realized my focus is on the
stone sitting behind it
not necessarily on the ring so i
apologize
for not super focus on the ring so here
i try to fit it and see if that fit
well so the ring looks fit really well
let's get on the buffing wheel and again
sorry to
lose the focus we want to polish
every part i was using the white diamond
and then i jump into fabblister
and i will put the link here in the
bottom
and this is the image of the polish
compound that i was using
now let's get to the song setting
first of all examine it and make sure
everything's nice and polished
because the wall is pretty thick for one
millimeter
or close to 0.8 millimeter so i like to
use
parallel plier to bend them first
because
it's almost impossible just push it
against it
the regular basal pressure is not going
to work because the thick
wall looking so i try to get it as close
as
possible that i can still slice the
stone in
so pretty much is the top i try to bend
it
the film is in two times to three times
uh
speed so you don't have to sit in the
whole section
but i just want to show you some key
point of him so there will be a lot of
trying
fitting it won't be done at just once
and final we put the stone and i would
like to tight it a little bit more
because of the thickness on the wall i
won't use
able to use the bezel pusher so i
actually use the
hammer to hammer on it be really careful
the angle that you are hammering it if
you hit the stone
the stone will crack right there what i
do is i use my finger to cover the stone
so if it does hit the stone it will hit
my finger
first you're ready to have a blues
finger instead of a cracking stone
and don't try to hammer too hard at once
what we like to do is bring it in close
one by one so you want to hit at three
o'clock
and then nine o'clock and 12 o'clock and
come back to six o'clock
this orientation like multiple times
you don't want to push for example three
o'clock all the way
so your stone will be crooked or you
won't be centered
again make sure you hit it at the right
angle you don't want
the corner to hit the stone and
sometimes it is really helpful
if you have a smaller face of the hammer
instead of a big face
when we get into the tight corner
instead of using a hammer i will get a
tracing hammer
and with the chesting tool and then that
will
have the better control so i will having
a hammer hitting on the end
of the chasing hammer to push the stone
down
to tight it and this is actually the
point you type the stone and make sure
that the stone is not
moving then we can go into the polish
process
once again i'm using the rubber wheel
here the rubber wheel will create
heat and this is really heat sensitive
stone
so make sure that your finger is always
somehow
testing the temperature on the ring that
you are setting
you can see my finger is always sitting
there to make sure that
it's not getting too hot if i feel is
too warm or too hot
i would really quickly to stop it
we want to get rid of all the hammer
marks that we have and
that's why i have this thick wall so i
can kind of smooth it out into the angle
that i like
and i like to have everything nice and
brown and more like an ache
shape so you can see that i try to
getting
to not only remove the hammer mark
but also smooth it out to the side
and once it is tight and everything is
smooth out we can go into the polish one
more time
i'm using the white diamond first and
then fabulous third
to shine up the ring since we already
have it pre-polished
and always need to have a high polish
before you set a stone
so when we the second time when we
polish we just need to polish
off where we leave the hammer mark
so your stone has the last chance to get
too much of heat
thank you for watching there are more
making videos
on those links here i hope you enjoyed
please like
share and comments on my video let me
know how i doing and what else you would
like to see in my channel
thank you for watching i'll see you next